pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle vous savez qui on attend ici ah non
ça serait pas un homme et arib rock par
hasard adressez vous à la réception
parce que je dois rencontrer un type de
ce nom et je pensais qu'il aurait pris
cet appartement maroc
ah bah c'est ça qui est broc arribes
rock ouï jamais entendu parler et bah ça
ne tardera pas c'est un chiffonnier
qu'est devenu milliardaire sans l'aide
de personne sauf celle des guerres un
homme qui pense aux gens d'apporter le
moment je n'aurais pas envie de le
rencontrer
voir et vous savez combien ils paient
pour pour sa 125 milles par jour 1 qui
vous l'a dit mon petit doigt
et alors elle va plier sur vingt cinq
mille par jour pour une chambre d'hôtel
ça devrait être défendu devrait y avoir
une loi est déjà tellement de loi pardon
je pense que cela grâce d'amis par
semaine je le rends pourquoi quelqu'un
dépensé 120 amis de l'argent aux
chambres d'hôtel exactement mais on va
dire que vous êtes mûr pour la
révolution ont pas répondu que j'y pense
mais sérieusement vous trouvez que ça a
changé
voilà washington oh pas assez à mon goût
on s'imaginait la bac après la guerre
les choses changeraient et puis on
revient on retrouve tout en place waouh
il ennuie avec monsieur ferrasse et que
vous penser trop beaucoup de garçons de
votre âge transport d'ailleurs
et là reste ici le reste euros
l'appartement au laser vu pour vous ça
suffira service terrasses et les
chambres à coucher par ici
bonjour monsieur broc que vous êtes beau
qui c'est à lui va savoir que ces
chèques cette toile avec des gens qui
vont et viennent dans tous les x madame
pro qui semble très satisfaite de ses
champs ses faveurs en bois qu à vous
comprends non ça va chercher pas croire
qu'on prend je suis un chercheur il ya
pas de madame brooks sauf ma mère et les
morts hors jeu comprendra et des vaincus
et merci monsieur merci infiniment bon
ça va ça va écouter un peu ce qu'il faut
aux services ici dit lors de le faire
bien et en vitesse il y aura pas de
pétards moi je boycotte pas pour les
pourvoir mais je n'aime pas voir des
gens qui rôdent tout le temps autour de
mes pattes puis j'aime pas à tordre
c'est pas dans mes habitudes je suis
certain que tout sera selon vous désire
monsieur bourassa
ça va ça va tirer bon séjour à
washington sherbrooke est
merci beaucoup monsieur mois mais les
bals à papa mal quelles études et
combien ça coûte par jour il a déjà
assuré les soirs l'a vu dans le propre
capital
dis donc il faut faire sur deux
contraventions 1 quels propos bas ont
roulé un peu vite en rentrant vise une
espèce de patates on unis font bon
j'aimerais à faire entrer dans ce qui
vous sert de crâne la notion suivante le
fait que je m'occupe de questions
légales ne signifie pas que les lois
dépendent de moi veut dire quoi ça 1
je suis pour rien moi je verrai ce que
je peux faire c'est encore doyen
toujours répugné ya deux ou trois
j'espère qu'ils peuvent pas tant il n'en
fait pas un missile qui voient encore
clé dans un contrat qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec le sénateur-maire à ça va
s'arranger ça coûtera peut-être un peu
plus contre penser mais ya pas lieu de
s'inquiéter
combien plus insignifiant pourquoi plus
c'est la loi de l'offre et de la demande
d'arrêt une conscience élastique est une
marchandise rare par ici par conséquent
coûteuse vous inquiétez pas ce que ça
veut dire ça vous inquiétez pas ces fois
là on peut pas les déclarer au
percepteur du temps à un pas sur quoi
peut-être créer un précédent
monsieur le percepteur je vous soient
obligés de déduire de mon revenu la
dépense suivant un pot-de-vin 40
millions ouais c'est ça que vous appelez
insignifiant vont nous pensions 25 n'est
ce pas être avare avec mon fric d'un
ouais ouais et la wii qui sait qu'il
demande
ouais un type pour vous vers al
allo paul moi ça va bien et la croisade
pour la morale publique
ça va mais quand vous voudrez le plus
tôt sera le mieux
un tout de suite oui j'y serai qu'est ce
que c'est que c'est sir paul gayral je
vous en ai parlé
les ramenant fait un journaliste de la
nouvelle république qui veut une
interview est un garçon de valeur il
revient de la guerre et qu'une bonne
provision d'idées et d'énergie
non je veux pas causer avec un
journaliste me faire raser feriez mieux
de poser avec lui qui signe là un
important foyer le pourquoi
c'est un des quelques types de
washington qu'on doit avoir le mettez le
dans votre jeu avant qu'ils ne
commencent à vous cherchez des histoires
reggae comment ma vie dit elle va bien
être là dessus je vais t'arranger
ouais c'est parti ah oui oui salon
coiffure pour le sénateur dit abily de
s'habiller simplement avec discrétion
après que sa femme
j'ai des jambes alors monté lui dire
ouais et si l'appartement de sherbrooke
mais oubliez tout de suite un garçon une
manucure et ça pour la barre qui
grouille ou un peu un lien coupe henri
godasses elmaleh pour les gones à ce
tigre hap et lee ho voulait le sauver la
vie au plate ou gazeuse sais c'est parti
elle va fait pas pour mille et une
choses pour elle elle sait s'habiller
c'était comme un simple coup de ses
robes pour ça ouais pourquoi alors j'ai
vraiment besoin de l'année seul dieu
sait combien de temps je vais rester à
washington leur nuit dans cette ville
c'est qu'ils aient un peu de secrets et
beaucoup de bavardages premier qui ouvre
sa gueule sur moi j'avais ford pour
parfait mais c'est pas précisément pour
ça que vous êtes venus ici
amusez vous à ça et adieu la haute
société washington que j'aurais à [ __ ]
ou qu'est ce que vous en avez à écouter
arrive
vous pouvez devenir un de ceux qui ont
ce pays en main mieux encore ce qu'ils
ont en main vous pouvez les tenir comme
ça
bon il faut de la puissance vous en avez
assez de l'argent vous en avais beaucoup
mais mais ce qu'il faut surtout c'est du
jugement et d'intelligence c'est
précisément pour ça que vous me donner
autant de fric mais qu'est ce qui vous
prend rien j'essaie seulement de définir
mon rôle c'est pas la peine de crier
dieu me pardonne on aurait vu que j'ai
fait quelque chose de mal
quand virale sera là soyez cordiale de
le bousculer pas traiter le comme une
fille que vous voudriez embarqué je vous
laisse avec lui c'est mieux il faut que
je parle au pôle salutaire à reebok au
libéral croit savoir monsieur brock
james maintien aussi je vous ai déjà vu
vous il n'ya pas longtemps puisque c'est
maintenant je vais me faire un jeu ça
vous dérange pas non non j'en ai vu
d'autres
si vous voulez bien m'excuser oui ça
s'est passé quelque chose
whisky si vous en avez qui changèrent et
les jette ma question vous croyez donc
j'étais fou répond j'ai eu juste le
débat en reste là et la nuit à whisky
soda aux plaintes au plateau aux plates
gin tonic pour toi exacte et c'est
toujours ce que j'ai envie de boire et
de l'emploi depuis tellement longtemps
plus en plus c'est mon cousin une
connaît comme sa poche
exact un peu mon neveu annoncé peut-être
lui que je devrais une interview et un
habillage requêtes creuser là ça serait
pas m qu'est ce que vous préparez la
nappe amadou le vitriol pourquoi j'aime
bien savoir avant le choc aux mieux si
je sais où on veut en dire nulle part
vous me dites la vérité c'est bon alors
c'est le vitriol c'est pas sur les vous
a fait pas et créé ce que vous voyez ça
m'est égal pouvait pas m'embêter vous
pouvez pas mener personnes
peu si je vous cause c'est parce que
t'être d'evry de la demande et paix dans
le pays assez cher pour qu'il me donne
des conseils
alors si je l'utilisé pas je ne devrais
pas exact un peu moins bon que sur toi
te tire toi
ouais merveilleux il aime bien qu'on
parle de moi dans les canards sinon même
monsieur broc surtout dans une ville
officielle comme washington il n'est pas
sans intérêt
bouclez là vous fait pleurer à
washington je mets toutes les villes que
je voulais dans la poche
en quelle différence avec washington un
cigare merci ça sera pour un député
kenna 1000 bahts piège qui me coûtent
ils sont roulés sur les cuisses de
femmes alors ce sera pour un sénateur
les sénateurs se débrouillait farissi an
plus tôt pourquoi il faudrait pas ça est
ce que c'est pour moi un sénateur un
type puisque 250 milles par semaine pas
un radis plus qu'est-ce que vous notez
votre petite remarque que chez mon père
ah oui premier rang était peut-être que
je réussirai la télé ben oui peut-être
pourquoi pas un bail et combien que je
fais plus d'argent que jerry lewis
je ne parie jamais hein
alors on y va qu'est ce que vous voulez
savoir le montant de votre fortune quoi
combien de millions vous avez est-ce que
je suis moi je suis pas mon comptable
vous ne savez pas pas exactement
milliardaire non mais vrai comme je vous
cause j'en sais rien plusieurs fois
peut-être une fois plus combien
ça va écouter ça j'ai fait chaque dollar
moi même jamais personne n'a rien donné
c'est du bon travail
ouais je le sent déçu qu'est ce que vous
avez à raconter sur moi non mais
attendez
mais si à l'aise ici ça me dérange pas
mais c'est bon qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la guerre continue évoluer démolissez
moi avait dit que je suis une frappe un
gougnafier ça me rapportera mais vous
êtes t il laissez moi vous dire un mot
de cliff là en 1947 là bas il ya un
grand dépôt de ferraille et la
municipalité veut s'en débarrasser
la camelote deux premiers alors j'y vais
pour me rendre compte
puis à d'autres mariole qui vont aussi
et venait de l'autre bout du pays est
encore plus loin moi je n'avais pas
l'ombre d'une chance et je le savais je
t'ai pas me dégonfler
quand tout à coup il ya un papier
terrible qui sort dans un journal du
patelin un article sur moi mais alors le
vrai passage tab 1 mon nom est tout
aussi la municipalité sur le point de
passer un marché avec des malfrats aient
oublié passe à 1
je suis pas la course et j'ai pas les
moyens qu'il faut pour ce genre de
combine le jour suivant et un médecin
et cette fois avec ma photo c'est ce qui
se passe un type de la commission
municipale m'appelle et bien devoir
publique et veulent pas l'histoire
alors on bavarde un peu tous les deux et
après moi je m'occupe au téléphone je
fais la somme avec deux cannes des 3 et
enfin arrive le bouquet legrand
terrassement en première page le
lendemain je signe le contrat et la
semaine suivant j'embarquais la camelote
et un orgue à la saveur que vous ne
pourrez pas venu en disant que je suis
une femme dira peut-être même que vous
m'aiderez ça fait peur aux gens mais
pour moi c'est bon les gens facilement
les fois peut-être pas tout le monde
beaucoup de monde là tout ce que vous
pouvez faire pour moi c'est ou me mettre
en avant tout la ferme est stupéfait ce
que tu dis qu'ici tu peux ici
quand je suis chez moi tous les matins
c'est lui qui bradent ouais j'ai un vrai
fauteuil de coiffeur exact un peu un jeu
alors mon petit gars a interviewé oui
tout mais dans la zone
chicago 1925 j'ai commencé à travailler
quand j'avais 12 ans et j'ai pas arrêté
depuis
et vous savez comment j'ai commencé en
ramassant les vieux journal ben j'avais
un concurrent dans le train aux gosses
qui s'est retiré des affaires avec un
bon coup de pied au cul et depuis vous
n'avez pas arrêté de travailler et je
vais vous dire pourquoi je suis un gars
de ma combi je la connais depuis 25 ans
la même combine l'acier la ferraille pas
d'acier cheechoo et la ferraille pardon
et pas de pommade un choc un chiffonnier
j'en ai pas mais il n'y a pas de réseau
je voulais à terre un petit gars jamais
truqués avec un truqueur je peux
posséder même les plus forts et ça a
marché pendant 25 ans je vais vous dire
en rampant chez moi je pousse et mon
petit chariot plein de journal je
n'étais pas le seul seulement les autres
gosses l'égard des mois je les vendais
je me faisais au 3 4 milles par semaine
et bientôt je découvre le vrai fils en
effet rien quand on doit oublier pas ça
mon client on arrive à me lâcher aux
huit à dix mille par semaine alors une
propose un arrangement à 5000 cette
patate
je vends les deux fois la même camelot
il y voyait que du feu
comment saint jacques mais je passais
derrière son hangar creusait un trou
sous la palissade chagra fait le papier
je le chargeait le lendemain matin
j'arrive devant sa porte
je déchargeais puis j'empochais
et tout ça à 12 ans dans ce jour là oui
et peu de temps après vous possédiez le
hangar croyez pas si bien des et la
patate en question c'est aujourd'hui
c'est un de mes employés
puis le monde peut sévir à coups de pied
dans le cul c'est aussi un de mes
employés
bah j'ai pensé que je devais bien ça
c'est comme ça que je suis moi six
dernières années ça a été deux années
pour la ferraille pas mauvaise
vous croyez pas que ça va plonger
parlait carrément ne vous pensez que le
marché va continuer à être bon non le
rendront bon we kiss à nous rien qui
nous tenons nous c'est moi ça suffit
j'aime pas les finasseries 1
vous voulez vous et c'est bon aussi bien
dans les apartés pas partez pas vous me
plaisez si vous essayez si vous jouer
franc jeu avec moi on ne peut pas
comparer très bien une seule fois et
tous domaines non mais bien elle ouvrait
pas un juste un polissage passes ont
fait descendre tous les jours qu'est-ce
que comme l acapa par là dans un coin
continuer continuer ça ne gêne pas
qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu faire à
washington pendant un oignon c'est quoi
mon avis ah oui pourquoi pas vous êtes
un personnage important monsieur ben
rhodes il est bien cherché à mettre au
bio quoi vous alors qu'est-ce que vous
êtes venu à washington avoir les
monuments c'est pour ça que je suis à
washington pour voir les monuments
laquelle médecins dans votre papier
comme ça les gens on reprend à trouver
ça dépend du nombre de monuments qu'il
faut voir on dit que vous pourriez
rester quelques temps et ont déjà bien
un petit peu partout un des salades
qu'est ce que j'en ai à figer la
politique moi j'ai assez à faire avec ma
propre combine je connais rien celle de
la politique a dit justement que vous
voudriez bien les apprendre écouter mon
petit grain jusqu'ici j'étais gentil
avec vous un alors n'essayez pas de me
pomper l'air c'est mon travail maroc
alors travailler pas trop avec moi 1
je veux qu'on respecte un nom une
enquête non ça se passe
un formidable il est né à chicago mon
vieux c'est tout ce que j'ai pu
apprendre jusqu'ici il est pas facile
entamé je comprends pas ils adorent
parler va pas avec moi comment je veux
raconter ma vie
il n'a même pas voulu me dire le montant
de sa fortune
je ne savais rien la même pas voulu me
dire pourquoi il était venu à washington
pas vos oignons aucun secret une simple
affaire d'impôts je voulais dire je sais
mais je n'en crois pas un mot à delhi je
vous présente mon ami paul béral une
belle vie dans toi tu y as où tu vas
avec celles non remède à sa place mais
je reste prudent je sais ce que tu
voudrais alors remet ça l'a acheté celui
de leur maître c'est tout mecheri non
y'a pas mort mais cela voilà relatons la
toile visite une visite importante or
c'est pas le moment de se noircir remet
ça là et mon change de robe et puis même
me cause pas complications tandis que
julie
et ça vous coûterait combien pour voulu
copier la gorge
un genre de plaisanterie que j'aime pas
beaucoup savaient pas non je m'énerve et
si je peux bon dieu arrive c'est une
plaisanterie je voulais tirer vous mais
moi aussi j'ai dit tout
partez pas partez pas ici tarde pas à
pas tous la paix vous êtes le seul avis
qui me rasant les parages
non mais je ne vais pas loin si on fait
des misères vous criez j'appelle non
c'est vous habitez l'hôtel oui parfaite
chaussée mais pas le même genre
d'appartements naturellement non alors
racontez pas d'histoires on me dit que
vous vous débrouillez très bien ça
l'était à bientôt un oui merci pour tout
et n'importe quoi je me sers de la
signature de billy sur quelques papiers
mais celle des digues en temps des mails
et des savoirs et mais qu'est ce qui
vous rend triste ouais je suis pas
triste
la voix vous fait la gueule je vois la
gueule question vous sentez trop vieux
moulin l'aspirine
alors je vais très bien depuis que je
vous connais je suis mort mais pour un
mort ne porte pas trop mal
c'est dingue un ciel parfois j'arrive
pas à me comprendre parfois est ce que
tu veux quelques papiers signés montout
c'est tout ce que je fais ici signé oui
c'est ça alors s'ils n'étaient toi et
bien quand est ce qu'il a acheté espèce
de sénateurs part d'un moment à l'autre
bon c'est être préparé oui comment vous
la trouvez comme ça allait bien ce qu'il
faut entendre par fait alors vous allez
bien sûr mais qu'est ce que j'y ai
encore celles dites moi c'est quelque
chose qui cloche et tête je veux pas
qu'ils aient de gaffe au départ aucune
raison vous inquiétez pas qu'est ce qui
lui prend lé veut produire une bonne
impression de signatures d'ici là
qu'est ce qu'on a fait toute la
paperasse que j'ai signé la semaine
dernière
on ne l'a pas perdue je parierais que
j'en ai déjà signer des milliers comme
ça voilà ce que c'est que d'être
administrateur d'une société à filiales
c'est ça que je suis c'est pas mal a
fait du chemin depuis vous étiez
figurante
j'ai pas toujours été figurante dans
tout va très bien j'avais du texte
vraiment qu'ils commun mais quelle
longueur qu'elle a encore de quoi le
texte
sailly je savais pas ma dernière portée
qui non mais je crois me dis si j'en
avais eu envie j'aurais sûrement plus
tous leurs dettes et pourquoi vous
n'avez pas continuer harry voulait pas
il aime se coucher de bonne heure ah
ouais je vois vous trouvez pas qu'il a
changé à rivaux comment changer
hfa autrefois ils avaient l'air plus gai
là c'est comme maintenant il arrêtait de
parler enfin comme à présent qu est ce
qu on avait besoin de venir à washington
c'est une longue histoire je veux pas
l'entente gimont-mauvezin y va tout ce
que je voudrais c'est qu'il reste un peu
tranquille l ambition bon bah je sais il
arrêtait de parler maintenant
tiens il me réveille la nuit pour me
raconter le grand bonhomme et il est
comment il sera quand il sera encore
plus grand et qui mènera tout comme ça
et c'est pas impossible
moi j'ai vu durant mon truc toute façon
je m'en balance mais beaucoup de gens
comme vous c'est pour ça qu'il a une
chance elle à plein notre époque c'est
le je m'en foutisme
c'est ce qui fait que le diable gagne à
tous les coups
qu'est ce que vous racontez vous êtes
tout autre chose
ouais je suis saoul et autre chose
bon bah on n'en parle plus d'accord
ouais
allez-y doucement vous n'allez pas vous
aimez vous fuit elle attendait un peu
billy vous irez droit quand ils sont
partis mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette affaire aux affaires des gens
importants à connaître
c'est quoi cette espèce de sénateur
madame herbert arrive a dit que ce type
travail est pour lui un certain sens
pourquoi il s'est tant de chichi alors
il va peut-être que ça continue trop
compliqué pour moi à tout ce que vous
avez à faire c'est est charmante et de
ne pas parler mais je n'ouvrirai pas on
vous en demande pas tant
puis gilles potvin des clash peut très
bien rester en haut
d'ailleurs c'est ce que je vais faire à
rennes m rapaces
je m'attendais bouchard a mal pas mal
anna via l'entente entre ces murs en
effet auprès d'un pardon bonsoir
sénateur vous un habitué des premières
vous ne voyez vous souvenir de cette
jeune dame elle s'appelait billy belle à
will we look parfaitement
oui je vous présente le sénateur charles
herbert donc je vous ai souvent parlé
très honoré et voici madame r b une très
heureuse moi de même si nous prenions un
ver marin jaune du pardon whisky parfait
parfait et les whiskys pur tout le monde
est parti enfin whisky je trouvais rien
souhaitent être mieux une chaussée ans
en commission peut être vous l'avez
dimanche et est le sénat a décidé de ne
rien décider
est ce qu'il vous plaît madame droite
oh j'ai encore rien vu pop aussi la
première fois comme nous ici est la
première joueuse et par les tournées de
province on fera visiter la ville elle
en vaut la peine
quel dommage que la cour suprême le soin
phase ans et si on vous adore
qu'est ce que c'est beaucoup de gens
voudraient connaître la réponse à cette
question
[Rires]
voilà ça fait droit à la plancha herbert
à willebroek
enfin c'est pas trop tôt ni dedans j'ai
vu mon avis je suppose que ça c'est ma
mère ben oui très bien vraiment pas mal
c'est vous c'est la terre c'est où merci
vous avez fait bon voyage très bon très
bon c'est ramener dans ma bagnole dans
ma voiture parce que tu aimes arrêtés en
route
oui à baltimore j'ai un partage 1 1 par
k ferraille
pas vraiment ah oui aux sommes un petit
truc de rien du tout qui vont même pas
tous les emplettes moi que ça me cause
mais je voulais un truc
j'aime bien c'est vrai c'est le deuxième
parc à ferraille que j'ai piqué avant
j'en avec un i combien en avez-vous bon
sens et [ __ ] rien j'aimerais pourquoi
j'ai un faible pour ce petit dépôt de
baltimore
c'est marrant on comprend les symboles
ce sentimental waouh voilà vous avez mis
le doigt dessus ses saveurs je suis un
sentimental je pense que nous sommes
tous un peu sentiment de howie et puis
c'était la liberté
bon alors qu'on n'a pas la tête on va
pour sauver la routine sont chers la
route immédiatement votre boulot jean de
la porte rien avec tous ces gens qui ont
être pendus à prévost pour retaper
ça fait partie du métier est-ce que vous
avez le bridge e madame broc n'ont rien
que le jean
adil rami nous sommes quelques jeunes
ses jolies formes qui nous nous
réunissons quelquefois pour jouer au
bridge
alors si cela vous plaisez à venise où
ben brik
tu pourrais reprendre si tu voulais si
tu pourrais fcl points
elle sait pas jouer en chine non plus
j'ai eu après puis maintenant elle elle
me décide à tous les coups est ce que
vous auriez du temps de libre de mes
choix et pas beaucoup malheureusement un
dommage voulu vous amener à rite ne veut
pas peu de choses et bien voulez-vous
ces trois mois deezer est ce que cela
convient et qui sait quoi dès 10 heures
du matin
oui et non ça c'est un peu tôt pour un
type m
alors on her eyes en soirée où ça chez
vous ah non quoi non je peux très bien
venir ici si vous voulez pas parfait
c'est c'est sur mon chemin
dimanche où vous avez pas besoin de vous
laver les mains ou autre chose
merci
est-ce que
sénateur est ce que vous seriez libre
vendredi soir à vendredi je ne sais pas
vendredi sont nous les brochets nous
pouvons enfin
as tu une femme et j'arrange un petit
dîner
petit dîner avec quelques personnes dont
je voudrais qu harry fasse la
connaissance oui et qui veulent le
connaître aussi sans aucun doute hausser
je suis qu'un chiffre lien et en
amérique ce n'est pas une tare non si
vous êtes un grand chiffonniers dites
moi je tiens à vous remercier monsieur
broc
ap - les sénateurs bon eh bien alors
harry je ne vous ai pas écrit
vous savez pourquoi mais je vais vous
sachiez que je vous suis très
reconnaissant de enfin pour votre disons
votre appui permanent
un quiz bourrin coup je me bourre et moi
il ya une catégorie d'hommes qui doit
toujours se tenir les coudes
oui c'est bien mon rêve non mais vous
savez ce qui m'intéresse moi la
ferraille j'achète je déménage avant
mais je vous prends convient de le
mettre des bâtons dans les roues avec
les règles et les règles oui à la banda
à la belge
c'est pas de la rigolade 1 vous imaginez
combien y en a de la ferraille dans tous
les coins du globe avec toutes ces
guerres n'ont aucune idée
moi non plus personne ne s'émeut y en a
encore plus qu'on peut se figurer
alors moi ce que je veux c'est l'art a
brassé cette ferraille l'apprendre là où
elle est et la ramener là que je peux
m'en servir qu'elle appartient cette
ferraille
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
j'ai pas vous justement une complice
d'une étude sur la question en fait non
mais vous annoncez un boulet la foulée
leur vitesse parce que moi j'ai pas de
temps à perdre avec les paperasses vous
allez moi ma façon de travailler c'est
comme ça chacun pour soi un oeil des
deux yeux est en chute de cendres
optiques avant qui vous décembre ah oui
on met ce que j'ai dans la tête c'est
une combine qui porte sur le monde
entier alors chacun y trouvera son
compte à condition dans le coup alors
jusqu'à présent ça va ça va on se
comprend dans ça tourne ça roule
mais maintenant ce que je veux c'est
démarrer un point c'est tout et c'est
ici oui oui oui oui oui mais tous les
jours dès que s'amène avec un autre
présentement on serait de mort si le
règlement là les tarifs links
l'administration partie des affaires
étrangères parle comprenez charles que
dans ce type d'opération suivant comme
hugo un buzz quoi ce type d'opération
des boniments tout ça moi je veux qu'une
chose il ya toujours un moyen de
s'arranger et tout ce que je vois et
salaires c'est à vous de trouver le truc
charles travaille dans ce sens arrivé
par exemple amendement que je déposerai
garantie l'entreprise privée contre
toute entrave nationale ou étrangère et
nous faisons tout pour qu'il soit voté
rapidement elle va veiller à ce que ça
se fasse un pas ce que c'est pour ça que
je suis ici pour voir si je peux obtenir
ce que je veux après avoir payé ce qu'il
faut oui ce qui veut donc non merci
là les coudes et trier rue d'la au
sénateur maire comment vous voyez la vie
en général et tout s'arrête
le bon dieu comme je le disais l'autre
jour à la tribune il s'agit de savoir si
c'est le peuple qui dirige le
gouvernement ou si c'est le gouvernement
qui dirige le club luc sala bref vous
l'avez dit non mais vous savez où j'en
suis maintenant si je devais démarrer ma
combinent dans la merde
excusez moi
bon très bien nous n'allons pas vous
déranger plus longtemps mon parti mais
pourquoi pourquoi partir on a tout le
temps non non ce n'était d'ailleurs pas
à proprement parler une visite non
bruyant que vous souhaiter la bienvenue
et du reste j'ai l'impression que nous
sommes appelés à nous revoir souvent
voilé ma chère tiens c'est un bon dans
les airs personnel vous êtes trop
aimable l'apport avons rigolé là alors
au revoir
harry a bientôt aux sénateurs un peu
plaisir pour moi enfin madame au crack à
la prochaine
au revoir et merci beaucoup mais de quoi
laisser moi m'installer vraiment ici et
je vous donnais le quoi me remercier
demain sera entendu au revoir
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va ça va aider les tire toi
tient pas à la minute
dénis de quoi c'est rien que des mythes
2 du nom mais pour qui tu te prends pas
pour parler comme ça les gens tu me
prends france khashi bon alors ça va
vous tuer la personne stationné excuses
m'a dit de lui au bond et montant encore
mon temps où se tenait
là aussi et vice président depuis quand
je suis plus que vice président avoue
dégringoler enfin j'étais le seul
président avant exact un peu mon neveu
pas au point que voilà une belle ferme
racines que tu m'apportes ans avoue t
elle pas tout simplifier les choses
cette mont-blanc est ce que vous allez
faire
tu sais pas tu sais pas si je m'écoutais
maintenant je balancerai un peu
compliqué non mais je sais sur le papier
alors qu'il a plus d'intérêt que vous
mais je côté c'est grâce à votre idée ça
une drôle de bonnes idées qui vous met à
couvert et vous évite de payer au
percepteur
vous savez combien mais oui vous l'avez
le joli mille fois excusez moi je m'en
bouffe à rimouski on cherchait quelque
chose parce que ça touche tous nos
petits chalets à cette sacrée garce
renvoyé à la maison
non mais qu'est ce qui vous en empêche
et le râteau non ça ne regarde plus les
conseilleurs ne sont pas les payeurs
quoi rien c'est un proverbe
mais ça veut rien dire oui si vous
voulez pays mais qui sait qui parle de
payer
personne n'a ri personnes ça va y avoir
un moyen d'aller mourir un peu
ouais peut-être une espèce décollement
l'enverrait est livré avec un cartable
bah quoi jeter pas peut-être pu tromper
quelqu'un qui veut apprendre les bonnes
manières
ah oui et comment hp y penser ouais nan
que nous sommes sur ce sujet il ya une
autre solution vous devriez envisager
l'arrêt mais laquelle est-ce que vous ne
pouvez vous passer de sa présence épouse
hélas pas pour moi pourquoi j'ai déjà
été marié j'aime pas ça depuis combien
de temps êtes vous connaissez vous me
dire tu prend 5,6 a répondu qu'est ce
qui cloche
bah c'est plus aussi le rôle après qu'on
ait mariska mais pour quelle raison mais
c'est comme ça vous ne demandez ça c'est
comme ça parce que c'est comme ça après
tout si on est ensemble et pas plus si
je fais un cadeau sur youtube un tube
vachement formidable si on est mario ne
pense que c'est lui et du chili n'est
pas comme ça ya une franchise toujours
une frange et il pourrait venir un jour
où vous le regretterez laisser tomber
comme vous voudrez il peut prendre et
pas pour une bille parce que je sais ce
que je fais mais je n'en doute pas non
c'est pas la peine de prendre au grand
air avec moi parce que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est vous qui bossait pour
moi personne ne dit le contraire
alors donnez vous conseille de suivre je
suis même pas ça me regarde
mais j'essaie puisque pour la peine de
faire votre bouche en cul de poule
pourquoi faudrait que je me marie comme
ça toute vitesse
vous êtes en pleine ascension a ri vous
entrez dans un milieu nouveau que peu
importe qu'il ya derrière les gens
importants tiennent aux apparences
qu'ils aillent se faire voir et c'est
tout vu vous êtes dans le grand cercle à
présent et le jeu s'il joue selon
certaines règles que les règles est une
règle est marié non mais une des règles
et de ne pas trop se faire remarquer le
pittoresque a des limites
on en cause mais tout ça je sais à sa
règle pas la question bill et ça peut
pas coller comme ça peut coller mais ce
soir je crois qu'il l'a ouverte lorraine
le fait de se taire et l'ennui c'est
qu'elle ne s'en rend pas compte
voyez pas lui dire devant deux mois ne
suffiront pas j'en ai peur et ben alors
quoi est un gros travail on ne refait
pas facilement une personne trop de
choses à expliquer mais ni l'âge ni la
patience dit même toutes les
connaissances qu'il faudrait pour
seconde quoi le type en bas et qui le
copain qui est venu pour l'interview le
petit mariole à aa
il connaît tout le monde il connaît bien
le coin il fait de jolies courbes est
mais conviendrait mais n'acceptera pas
pourquoi parce que c'est pourquoi je le
paierai ce qu'il voudra c'est ce que
vous pariez
comment il s'appelle déjà non je pense
pas que vous devriez moi je pense que si
halo halo pas ses mots envers al oui oui
monsieur verra vous embarquez passivité
bonne gueule
alors un bon petit gars thierry brun
quel appareil et donc qu'est ce que vous
faites là j'ai moi-même bavarde avec
vous et maintenant j'ai une proposition
à vous faire quoi nadal a une
proposition honnête aulas absolument
régulier ben c'est sa fête dans sa non
mais non je bouge pas laissé toutes ses
plaintes gala il vous plaît assez pour
l'avoir ici tourner autour de pili tout
le temps pour hirvonen on vous l'avait
vu avec ses lunettes
mais je vous le dis c'est le bon truc je
le sens je leur en effet billy sera
peut-être pas d'accord
elle fera ce que je vous dirai ça suffit
pour ses instructions aux côtes à
comprendre que c'est pour son bien
marché on vous la connaissez mieux que
moi un peu oui dit m comme je voulais
offrir aux petits as à votre place je
resterai sur un plan purement amicale
mais moi je crois à rien sur un plan
amical puisque les chars de type
reconnaît l'état type c'est toujours le
fric qu'est le dernier mot et je veux
pas que personne ne rendent des services
à la ville par l'est lui d'abord voyez
ci entend un bon petit gars entre cce
mieux j'ai j'ai quelque chose à vous
demander
je vous écoute combien vous gagnez par
semaine
est-ce que chez moi je suis pas mon
comptable ah j'adore ce gars là
commencez votre moral non l'apprenant
paul labonne rabat la bonne voie les
affaires j'ai une amie c'est une bonne
gosse mais vous la connaissez un voyage
vous l'avez déjà vu ici bébé
ah oui oui voilà bah c'est une chicken
seulement deux voix - elle n'a pas
inventé l'eau chaude
ouais on pas figé face aux fontaines
figurer dans les revues alors pour
figurer en savait assez souvent j'ai
peur qu'elle s'ennuie dans une ville
comme washington
voilà je le faisais avec des gens comme
y en a ici alors monsieur v n'en a pas
du tout non voilà je pense que senghor
comme vous pourrez les des frappes
ça m'aidera aussi par la même occasion
oui de quelle façon n'en joue pas moins
20 oui mais quelle approche quoi vont
vous lui apprenez les bonnes manières
un nom à avoir vos moments perdus bien
entendu si vous en avez non je ne crois
pas que je sois qualifié
excusez moi monsieur je vous donnerai
deux cent mille par semaine d'accord
ce que je dis c'est là à mpm en juin bon
alors on commence quand
bah tout de suite pourquoi pas ok je
vous la mène mais vous prenez les
pouvoirs mais et savoir une minute
là bas tu ne souhaites moi tout seul ne
suis pas habillé t'inquiète pas ça ami
de la famille est belle et sauf et je te
dis je n'avais pas libérale et votre
cause est rude à coire assieds toi tu
verra bien ted montant wilmington voilà
les papiers oui
[Musique]
voilà votre enfin monsieur broc voudrais
que nous voyons de temps en temps enfin
je veux dire que nous nous voyons vous
et moi sans blague
oui il fait gigolo maintenant non non
pas exactement qu'est ce que ça signifie
alors eh bien il faudrait que je vous
tienne au courant de tout ce qui se
passe washington que je vous met à la
page que je ne sais pas moi que je
réponde à vos questions il pas de
questions à
eh ben je vous en suis gèrerait alors et
après bah je sais pas ça pourrait être
amusant non vous savez il ya beaucoup de
choses à voir à washington je pourrais
vous servir de guide et cette cour
suprême vous la connaissez oui mais
temps-là au programme après entendu bon
alors on commence on commence quoi bas
notre petit programme moi ça m'est égal
je n'ai pas grand-chose à faire un beat
bon il vous fait combien pour ça deux
cent mille par semaine pas mal aux vous
pouviez lui en prendre plus il est plein
fric où je leur ai fait pour rien ah ah
et pourquoi reçu parce que c'est pas un
travail ça me plaît ils pensent que je
suis une gourde un nom mais il pense que
quelques feuilles la pâte à choux une
gourde et j'aime ça
ah bon vous aimez ça bah oui moi je suis
heureux j'ai tout ce que je désire g de
manteaux de vison tour quoi quand j'ai
besoin de quelque chose ville morte
pisi marche pas et ben c'est moi qui
marchera pas si vous voyez ce que je
vais dire oui toi bien oui
c'est ce que j'ai besoin de savoir c'est
de savoir comment obtenir ce que je veux
oui si vous savez ce que vous voulez une
mafia certains font quoi si vous savez
ce que vous voulez audit pour la mise en
boîte vous repasserez un homme et non
mais pas du tout je vous assure quoi
frémont c'est ce que je voudrais c'est
apprendre à bien causer d'accord c'est
difficile non pas tellement comment ils
vont faire
et bien je vous préfère d'abord quelques
libre et puis si vous le permettez je
vous dirai quand vous faites une faute
allons-y
ben je vous dirai quand j'amène
apercevrez parce que je ne cause pas
toujours très bien moi même je dis
jamais gros mots vous avez remarqué
jamais quand j'étais môme le prof
d'afficher une bonne baffe si on disait
alors j'ai pas pris l'habitude ça
méritait peut-être pas une chez moi
c'était une grande gifle remet enfin
tout de même mais je ne sais pas pour
les punitions je n'y crois pas moal en
plus j'y crois pas je je je je n'y crois
pas mieux
j'apprends vite
il faut pas dire un j'apprends vite
n'est ce pas formidable heath bell billy
do pill d'après nos bizarre sa fille dit
bizarre la moitié des filles que je
connais s'appelle billy d'avoir c'est
pas mon vrai prénom
quel est votre vrai prénom vous croirez
pas m ma vie après est ce que j'ai une
tête à ma pme à quoi je ressemble vous
n'êtes pas non plus une billy je vais
vous le dire pour moi une pour vous pour
moi vous ressemblez un petit ange dit
vous êtes en train de me faire du
boniment vous n'êtes pas allé plus loin
est ce que moi j'ai fait chiper pour
vous du premier coup un bon ça vous
arrive souvent dans un tas et qu'est ce
que vous faites va rester un peu vous
verrez bien
bah c'est ça je vais rester je vais voir
et si vous voulez un tuyau écouter
parler moins qu'alain j'aime ça comme
cette histoire de petit ange là vous
inquiétez pas pour lui voit rien à lui y
voit que lui il se bouchent la vue ça
risque d'être légèrement différent de ce
que j'imaginais
vous le regrettez eux non respect
réciproque
comme ça chacun fera l'éducation de
l'autre
pour en revenir au livre michel je vous
laisse apporterait demain je regarderai
ce que j'ai chez moi
si je trouve quelque chose d'intéressant
je ne dis pas que je ne revienne pas
tout à leur revenir
le programme du lendemain nous
l'établirons chaque jour
où chaque nuit oui c'est ça oui à
commence à cols bleus n'ont rien ça
choque c'est à manger hao wawa super
nanny qu'est-ce que vous prenez excédent
de marée ouais adama l'insomnie voilà
bientôt fussent je suis très content oui
moi aussi
à bientôt six ans
[Musique]
le jeu
depuis quarante huit 48 48
si tu écoutes ce type verra là ça sera
pas mauvais pour toi d'accord jeté dans
le grand cirque à présent alors
fais gaffe ou tu mets les pieds un
d'accord tu apprennes à bien de tenir
parce que ce soit moi je peux pas garder
ici puis c'est pas des salades on fait
attention à ce que tu dis puis fait
autre chose que tu fais toi 28 28 28
un peu d'éducation ça ne ferait pas mal
à toi aussi tu veux mon avis tu te
demandes personnes
on va leur parle pas
je peux pas parler joue s'il paye la
liberté on tutoie qu'ils déjeunent
tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut
pas mal acquis tout à fait rêver
51 51
bitz et ses hôtes avaient jeté blake ah
oui quand c'est fini qui dit le
contraire
bâle 7325 paye tout de suite tu sais pas
où tu n'as pas confiance pourquoi tu
tribune fait toujours payé moi comme ça
27 1325
merci
vient de coucher dans son nom maintenant
dans une minute je te dis pas bon soir
moussa
je vous ai apporté les journaux c'était
pas la fête je lis pas les journaux
jamais dans un temps les bandes
dessinées à la dernière page vous
devriez lire aussi la première pourquoi
c'est pas sans intérêt pas pour moi
enfin comment savez vous puisque vous ne
lisez jamais aussi vous tenez absolument
à devenir un casse qui dit que tout de
suite
forest petit mieux annuler notre petit
programme on fait 30 ans jette un coup
d'oeil sur les journaux mais j'y
comprends rien alors à quoi vous lisez
ceci s'il ya quelque chose que vous ne
comprenez pas vous ferez des marques et
demain je vous donnerai des explications
d'accord d'accord
tenez je vous ai aussi apporté des
livres je pense qu'il vous intéresseront
plus j'essaierai
ah non non non il faut pas les traiter
comme ça vous commencez par en prendre
un vous lisez
s'il vous plaît pas vous arrêter et vous
prenez les autres oui mais ya autre
chose ça me fait mal aux yeux et bien
porter des lunettes de luxe
oui pourquoi pas mais c'est en règle
[Musique]
et aux âmes ça leur va pas si mal
bien bonne idée
banier
[Musique]
m
c'est vrai ça gaze bonjour bonjour
jolies dames où tout va bien ça va pas
mal ça ça ne va pas mal affectés non
merci
c'est joli cette musique sibelius
concerto opus 47
devinez qui est venu boire le thé
tu es venu prendre le thé bien qui la
femme du sénateur
comment ça s'est passé ne m'en parlez
pas elle aussi elle est pas mal idiote
mais s est d'une manière distinguée
on n'avait pas grand chose à se dire
alors elle a été amenée à remarqué alice
qui étaient là qui qui est hélas et vous
savez ce qu'elle a dit oh mon dieu voilà
des années que je voudrais leur lire
quel livre sa victoire 6
alors on en a parlé et vous savez ce que
j'ai découvert non qu'elle n'avait
jamais lu comment le savez-vous à la
manière dont elle en parlait mais ça
vous a surpris
quoi qu'elle n'a jamais lu oui bah non
mais pourquoi fait-elle semblant c'est
pas un crime de pas en fait de ne pas
l'avoir lu ah ben tout le monde agit de
même plus ou moins vous aussi parfois
vois pas je sais billy vous possédez une
grande vertu l'honnêteté merci je suis
contente d'avoir acquis quelque chose en
deux mois
j'y suis pour rien pardon je n'y suis
pour rire j'ai aussi pas sûr merci pas
de quoi non merci merci merci
vous savez j'ai reçu une lettre ce matin
de mon père le new york
j'arrête pas d'y penser pourquoi c'est
la première fois qu'ils mécréants huit
ans on s'était un petit peu disputés il
voulait pas que je me mette avec harry
qu'est ce qu'il fait mon père employé du
gaz
y relever les compteurs dans sa lettre
et vicky pouvait plus faire sa tournée
comme autrefois là ils lui ont donné à
notre boulot car sans d'ascenseur quel
phénomène
tous les matins il partait avec sa
petite casserole et son petit réchaud et
utilisait son déjeuner il disait que
tout le monde doit avoir un déjeuner
chaud je vous jure j'ai pas comment il
sait nous étions quatre mais trois
frères et moi maman était morte
eh ben ils nous faisaient la cuisine ou
la veille nous à billets tout bois
j'ai toujours pensé que je rendrais ça
un jour mais les choses s'arrangent
drôlement parfois un jour je rentre à la
maison avec 50000 je lui donne vous
savez ce qu'il en a fait ils achetaient
là où je pense qu'il a tiré la chaîne
j'ai cru qu'il allait me taper dessus un
sans blague
il n'a pas fait dans toute sa vie il m'a
jamais tapé dessus une seule fois
pourquoi vous at il écrit
enfin je veux dire après tant de temps
parce que je lui avais écrit à mon dieu
il dit qu'il pense à moi chaque jour je
suis sûr que j'ai pas pensé à lui tient
une seule fois en cinq ans
oh c'est pas que j'avais quelque chose
contre lui non mais j'ai pensé à rien ce
serait gentil d'aller le voir
ted bien mais dit que je dois livrer
encore qu'il faut que j'aie un déjeuner
chaud chaque jour qu'il faut que je dise
comment je vais seulement il dit qu'il
peut pas voir si je continue à vivre
comme une concubine concubine
j'ai vérifié le mot dit je vous à peu
près raconter toute ma vie quand est ce
que vous me raconterez la vôtre oh non
ça ce serait trop long est en grande
partie inexacte
qu'est ce que vous avez fait ce matin
ce que l'on m'avait dit tu elle aussi
les mains voir les actualités et puis
chez les libraires j'ai vu des tas de
bouquins et ceux qui m'ont paru
intéressant je les ai achetés dieu mais
attendez bientôt j'en ai eu tout un
groupe a quel si gros que je pouvais pas
le porter alors je me suis arrêté
je me suis dit mon dieu il va falloir au
moins là pour lire tout ça alors faire
garder tous les riffs qui restait dans
la boutique puis à côté mon paquet il
avait plus l'air de rien du tout alors
là j'ai compris que même si je musée les
yeux à lire tous les jours jusqu'à ma
mort je réussis la même pas faire une
petite poche rien dans cette seule
boutique et vous savez ce qui est arrivé
je me suis mise à pleurer mais personne
n'a jamais lu tout ce qu'on a écrit
voyons personne naturellement
moi je voulais essayer je pense que vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de lire mon
article
qu'est ce que vous racontez bien sûr
j'ai eu deux fois
comment trouvez vous je pense que c'est
le meilleur article que j'ai jamais j'ai
pas compris un mot
et qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas compris
venez montrer moi ça vous trouvez ça
drôle que je suis myope comme une taupe
non que je sois que je sois bien pas
longtemps j'avais peur que j'avais l'air
si drôle mais vous êtes encore plus ravi
cerveau ça va parler pas comme une
réclame pour les lunettes
bon alors là rien que le début le
manifeste démocratique n'est plus qu'un
document jaunissant c'est ce n'est pas
pour moi enfin vous savez ce que ça veut
dire joli sens pas pour le moment
qu'est ce qui arriva vieux morceaux de
journal pour les fiche en l'air
non il jaunit sa blague mais oui c'est
pour ça bon démocratique où c'est ce que
ça veut dire
faites comme si je le savais
pour démocratique ça veut dire qu'ils
procèdent de notre type de gouvernement
lequel est une démocratie manifeste
maintenant alors là pourquoi vous n'avez
pas regarder dans le dictionnaire mais
j'ai regardé les chais toujours pas
quand je parle de manifeste de moi
j'entends parler d'un ensemble de règles
d'idéal de principe d'espoir qui
conditionne l'existence d'une nation
et vous pensez que chez nous ça jauni je
crois qu'on a perdus de vue l'idéal
démocratique et ça fait mauvais et ça
c'est ça que vous avez voulu dire oui
mais pourquoi vous l'avez pas écrit je
je devrais peut-être faire mon article
oui vous savez cette chose que vous
n'allez données à propos de napoléon
oui j'ai rien compris non plus haut
pourtant c'est facile
l'auteur se rend sur le tombeau de
napoléon et il pense cnafal y en a une
vie par gay voilà qu'il aurait mieux
aimé être à fermer
je pense que j'aurais mieux aimé être un
paysan de france que j'aurais mieux aimé
vivre dans une chaumière à la porte
entouré de treilles ou des raisins
rouges hisse au soleil d'automne
comment vous faites pour retenir tous
ces trucs là
une fois de temps en temps ça me repose
il faut pas exagérer moi je ne veux pas
vous contraindre mais j'aimerais est ce
qu'on doit t mais je te la place pour
tous billy bon alors il aurait mieux
aimé être un simple paysan napoléon bas
qui aimerait lui est napoléon personnes
en bas des tas de gens riches et brode
par exemple qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça a demandé le lui faudrait d'abord
qu'ils achetaient napoléon d'abord
qu'ils sachent qu est un paysan fait pas
le sentir
puis avec we are in on voulait mais tout
de même pas non non c'est à cause de lui
et moi non pas seulement non c'est une
raison mais y en ad'autres nickel c'est
un danger public ce type
on me dit qu'il a géré les pas si
mauvais enfin at il jamais fait quelque
chose pour quelqu'un d'autre pour lui
oui powell quoi il m'a donné deux
manteaux de vison
mais c'était pas pour rien qu'on lui
avait donné quelque chose en échange non
ne soyez pas grossier à l'homme aussi
parfait que vous ne doit pas être
grossier
enfin at il jamais pensé à quelqu'un
d'autre qu'à lui mais qu'il pense aux
autres mais 8 millions de chants toute
l'histoire de notre foutu société sept
présidents de l'histoire de la lutte des
égoïstes contre les altruistes je
comprends pas toujours mais j'entends
bien tout ce qu'il ya de mauvais
mon fils y revient de l'égoïsme ya des
périodes où l'égoïsme devenu une cause
mouvement et le gouvernement vous
entendez et ça s'appelle le fascisme ça
vous comprenez à peu près alors pensez-y
bien billy vous êtes bien chiper pour
moi un que vous l'êtes
oui c'est pour ça qu'ils arrivent au
rang d'un gain non non non non ça je
déteste ce qui fait ce qu'il représente
mais lui lui il se rend pas compte
je crois que vous m
c'est autre chose que d'être chiper
c'est à cause de ça que j'ai commencé
tout ce travail vous le saviez gants non
encore ça m'a réussi
cet agent temps mais j'avais jamais
connu avant ça je peux vous dire que
l'ennui mais après le premier soir où on
s'est rencontrés j'ai cru que ça irait
tout seul mais comme vous vous décidiez
pas aller plus loin là je me suis dit
que le seul chemin pour m'approcher de
vous passez par là noté maintenant ça
n'a plus d'importance et je vous aime
bien comme ça mais pour le reste est un
peu tard pourquoi pourquoi écouter pâle
entre un homme une femme un certain
moment bas ça marche ça marche pas après
ce moment là ça marche jamais l'autre
moment n'était peut-être pas encore
arrivé si et vous avez loupé l'occasion
n'en soyez pas si sûr belli pour hbo je
le sais vous savez des autres j'en ai eu
quelques-uns puis j'en ai eu aussi
beaucoup que j'ai paru si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire oui chauffeur alors sur
ma vie dit pour un aveu fait fourrer
dans ce genre de pépins mais qu'elle
peut très bien pourquoi es-tu d'y
réfléchir se faire de la ville tous ces
trucs là tiens cette nuit dans mon lit
je me mets à réfléchir comme ça bêtement
[Musique]
vous savez combien de temps gêné à
m'endormir dix minutes
billy personne mais mes instruit voyons
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus belle au
monde un nouveau né si vous avez contre
les bébés l'ida cours non non vous ne
comprenez pas je veux dire que si un
cerveau de trois semaines est vide c'est
normal mais si après 30 ans il est
toujours vivre ça c'est pas normal
qu'est ce qui vous fait croire que j'ai
plus de trente ans mais je parlais pas
de vous la g2 qui alors je vous jure
vous avez des manières d'arranger les
chambres excusez moi ça après tout
autant est ce que j'ai l'air des verts
tentant non alors pourquoi vous dites je
sais pas je quel âge avez vous 29
bien continuer mais je veux dire
continuer à étudier
quoi vous ne voulez pas oui mais ça fait
mariage
qu'est-ce-qui rigolerait les gens s'ils
savaient que j'ai c'est en fait ce que
je ris moi tous ces bouquins là partout
mais billy se sont pas les vivres qui
compte c'est l'étude vous savez ce qu a
dit popp
quel pop alexander pope
oui je sais il a dit l'étude la plus
utile à l'humanité c'est l'étude des
hommes ça veut dire aussi l'étude des
femmes oui bien sûr mais oui je le sais
alors ne vous souciez pas trop des
livres vous savez en étudiant jean
jacques rousseau comme vous m'avez dit
ça m'a amené à penser à rite liste est
tellement de mal pour avoir ce qu'il
veut seulement voilà il c'est parce
qu'il veut il peut toujours ce qui n'a
pas nouvelle free depuis marché sur les
autres
vous exagérez il est pas si mauvais je
sais je sais il a un coeur en dehors
salut on paraît justement le vous arrive
ouais bah c'est pas bon c'est que je
vous plais sur mayence est assez long
trop long même si c'était des paluns non
mais pourquoi bon dieu voilà ils doivent
attendre ici
bien revenu à jean jacques rousseau
alors que pensez vous de lui
c'était un grand type non au oui tilly
ne vous en souvenez rocher pas à genève
ou en suisse enfin dans un coin comme ça
tu ça veut dire st-gelais poumon
celui-ci c'est la même chose
ah oui ben je l'aimais tant suisse
genève est une ville
la suisse est le pays d'accord pour feu
de dieu question est qu'est ce que vous
avez comme patience voilà vous en faites
pas pour moi
mais comment on peut être bête comme ça
on ne peut pas tout savoir et jean
jacques rousseau tu sais qui c'est par
exemple
ouais t'as entendu jean jacques rousseau
jeu j'en ai à [ __ ] de savoir qui c'est
ouais je sais et après si je voulais
savoir qui c'est je le sors et je m'en
fous piché donc continuez vous vous
laissez pas déranger bien
lequel de ces vivres avait voulu fusil
pas encore vu ses livres mais j'ai lu un
livre sur lui un ferraillage et ministre
qui c'est jack johnson qui jack johnson
je ne sais pas et si je voulais savoir
je le saurai mais je m'en fous
moi qui te croyais calais le premier
noir champion du monde de boxe poids
lourds a conquis son titre sur tommy
burns en australie que vous êtes vous un
petit génie non pas parce que des petits
génies challenge et jean-michel
apportent tous les jours sur arize sur
bien alors cette liste je vous conseille
de commencer par rémy de l'éducation et
1000 ou les ducasses ça vous serions en
mesure qui s'est uni hop champion de
billard d'ailleurs selon ce diplomate
et qu'est ce que je disais je me
demandais rien vous celle que je cause
au partant bien qu'ils se disaient déjà
on était jmil ou l'éducation bon un coup
d'oeil aussi sur le contrat social le
contrat social ça vous donnera quelques
sécu péninsule jetons mais dallas mais
ne me fais pas puisque tous ces si la la
qu'est-ce que c'est une péninsule une
péninsule en pas vous c'est ce nouveau
médicament
ah ah
ben non c'est pas ce à quoi l'on est une
étendue de terre entourée d'eau sur
trois côtés
la belle avance mais alors attends c'est
comme un jean paul rousseau cette avance
à quoi nous y a aucune comparaison
jean jacques rousseau et pas jean paul
est mort en 1778 et on en parle encore
tu supprimes parfait en 1778
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend vous les
tops cette date de le prendre des trucs
sur des gars qui sont morts moi ce que
je veux c'est qu'il n'ait pas l'air
d'une bourde avec les vivants et on ne
contrôle pas si facile or l'éducation
harry une chose en amène une autre il
faut former son intelligence son
jugement ou non mais ça va ça va elle a
besoin de leçons par mois c'est dommage
ce sera sans supplément d'âme à prendre
mais je crois au contraire que nous
pourrions beaucoup nous apprendre l'un à
l'autre ça veut dire quoi ça un petit
avion passant qui vous le demande et non
pour impôts mais vous manquez pas la
grâce à payet belle vous le savez pas ce
que je faisais alors oui moi et bien
comme ça on s'observe tous les le pot à
tabac vous casser la gueule chez oui je
sais bon alors on continue à donner vos
leçons puis c'est tout c'est ça c'est
tout c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
non non non cotés en continu et non je
veux voir comment vous vous y prenez pas
maintenant si vous voulez bien il faut
que j'aille m'allonger quoi c'est dur
monsieur ce que je suis en train de
faire 200 milles par semaine que ça vous
coûte
je vous donnerais volontiers des sceaux
particulière j'ai des cours du soir pour
milliardaires micro ses fans salut
key a juré vous en suis qu'elle couche
aïe
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que cette
affaire que nous faisons ici nous que ça
veut dire non je croyais que j'étais
quelque chose comme un associé à mâcher
muet alors parle pas j'ai le droit de
savoir
table ronde à boucler cet ovale et pour
ta tête d'anthony west si tu peux rien
d'illégal à c'est moi qui te le dis tu
fais ce que je te dirai un mot que tu te
plains c'est quelque chose que tu
voudrais quoi je voudrais être un paysan
euros je te lâche retrait
arrête de mai car c'est un bon tirage
mais enfin terminé il vise à plis au
patro vraiment oh non je m'en sens pas
pour juger ces histoires là quand on
vous raconte que c'est triste de trop
riche mais pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas
être riche et traîné pour qu'on pourrait
pas la montée est la lecture et vous tu
sais moi c'est brad may soit pas
tellement copain avec tout le monde
when i qui la faute on s'en balance je
te dis pas moi j'aime pas ça toi tu sais
ce que tu fais quoi
un outil social tu parles
et plutôt deux fois qu'une alors vous
étiez forêt vous de vous savez leur
désolé d'être toujours isolés mais c'est
moi le coupable
bonsoir bonsoir sénateurs asseyez vous
je vous prie je vous remercie
[Musique]
j'avais des choses à laval alors ça va
ça
la quoi de neuf
eh bien juste un petit ennui yari j'ai
peur que ça ne demande un peu plus de
temps et un petit peu plus de d'argent à
cause
la première raison c'est que
l'amendement doit être modifié non je
veux pas le modifie je peux pas attendre
ne me dis pas ce que je dois je sais
rien du tout et j'ai l'impression qu'en
ce que le mayon assure que charles fait
tout son possible les ballons parce que
ça suffit pas soyez raisonnable il ya 96
votons et shine et plein d'humour et
ballades et celui qu'il fallait pas
prendre crois pas que c'est déjà fait
avant long mais les choses ne sont plus
pas été bon mais bon les fera pareil
c'est votre boulot non c'est pas très
facilement faux bon je vous conseille de
vous même ou sans ça je voulais money et
vous vous retrouvez dans la panade vous
êtes sorti oui je pourrais travailler où
je veux quand je veux comme je veux
autant que je veux si vous n'êtes pas
avec moi quand je suis avec vous alors
parfait maîtrisant à nombre de coups un
parce que souvent quelqu'un qu'il devait
être à votre place
c'est clair votre temps
il a un tempérament un peu vif
attention ils parlent pas ils aboient
le whisky combattants maï et non merci
non je trouve car il devrait pas vous
parler sur ce ton
après tout vous êtes un sénateur vous
savez je trouve que personne ne devrait
parler un sénateur sur ce ton un
sénateur c'est quelque chose mais quand
ils vous engueuler c'est comme si
l'anglais des millions de gens quel
genre mais les millions de gens qui vous
hante et lui il n'y en a pas autant
combien 800 6400 cas ça fait tout de
même pas mal qu il engueule
mais dites-moi est-ce que par hasard
vous feriez partie de ma circonscription
je crois que je connais pas ce mot là le
sénateur roulement si vous n'êtes pas un
des électeurs qui ont voté pour lui
jamais voté pour personne
et pourquoi chez poche je serai pas
comment faire c'est simple vous prenez
un bulletin vous le mettez dans l'urne
oui lesquelles bulletin vous lisez les
journaux vous écouter la télé vous
faites une idée quand vous avez pris un
parti
vous n'avez qu'à voir qui est de votre
côté et qui est contre c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça oui mais pourquoi vous
vous laisser piétiner par harry c'est ça
que je voudrais savoir enfin vous êtes
plus important que lui
vous êtes un sénateur oui et comme tels
jets de grands devoirs voyez-vous de
grandes responsabilités et est alors
gouverné est une entreprise complexe
oui mais pourquoi quand je lis des
livres là dessus ou que paul m'explique
je comprends et quand je vois ce qui se
passe c'est différent mais en quoi je
vais dire quand on en vient à parler de
ce qui est la loi ou de ce qui est pas
la loi
enfin est-ce que harry est plus
important que les autres non alors
pourquoi il à voir ja pitre après tout
personne a voté pour lui bon écoute et
nous aurons là dessus une longue
conversation un de ces jours j totem
c'est promis bonsoir
mais elle a cinq ans à peine en dessous
enfin pourquoi j'ai quelques petites
choses pour vous
qu'est ce que c'est genre la même
histoire quelle histoire
comment expliquer j'aime qu'on
m'explique j'ai découvert sain une autre
fois tout de suite vous les jeudis
zurichois que vous voulez pas signé
qu'est-ce qui vous parle de ça j'ai
simplement savoir ce que c'est une
fusion c'est à dire plusieurs sociétés
qu'il en devienne qu'une seule et toute
la partie n est arrivé non acquis alors
certaines sont taries d'autres à des
sociétés étrangères
anglaise italienne un trust
de quoi vous parlez la nôtre c'est
justement contre les traces de suie
olympique et le mécanisme une opération
est parfaitement régulière vous
inquiétez pas blague demandé harry
attendu il aimera pas ça et pourquoi ils
la voient pas ça c'est tout alors il
aime pas les gens trop curieux je ne
suis pas à l'aise
bon écoute et billy tâcher d'être un peu
malines comment voulez-vous que soit mal
ici personne ne me dit rien moi moi je
vous dit quelque chose
quoi de signer pas faire d'histoires
demain pourquoi demain parce que je vais
examiner ses papiers savoir ce que je
fais mais je vous dis que tout est
régulier il doit y avoir quelque chose
de louche sinon vous ne diriez plus lots
bons côtés - billy je vous donne
maintenant je sais ce qu'il vous
chatouille vous n'aimez pas verte faire
son sale métier votre seul métier que
vous salle être plus avec vous pas les
niveaux lasser et puis je n'en suis pas
sûr peut-être que vous êtes encore pire
que lui
intéressant pas trop pas habitués à lire
des trucs aussi terre-à-terre non qu'est
ce qui se passe mais belle comme ça là
tout d'un coup je n'aime pas perdre
mais qu'est ce qui t'a fait à moi rien
c'est pas lui qui l'a fait quelque chose
al oui tu sais qu'il a été l'assistant
des ministres de la justice il ya pas de
mal à ça tu as vu où il est maintenant
seul et tu sais qu'il a écrit un livre
autrefois les sources de la liberté que
ça s'appelle je les lui c'est magnifique
et alors qu'a fait ce qui fait à présent
il fait n'importe quoi pour toi et
encaisse ton argent il doit tout le
traite comme un garçon de coureurs et
finalement on arrive à moi et je suis
pas sûr que tu vas y mieux que lui qu un
égoïste voilà ce que tu es depuis quand
à bruxelles depuis maintenant aux ja tu
m'en diras tant tu sais harry je croyais
que tu étais un grand type plus
maintenant dans l'histoire tu sais ya eu
des types bien plus grand toit les
meilleurs il y en a encore eu que par
exemple des milliers nos mains
25000 par semaine car d'art quoi rien ni
dans ma belle pour être pas t'énerver
parce que tu as lu un ou deux bouquins
tendent à une couche aussi épaisse
qu'avant tu sais tu crois pas de doute
là dessus
seulement je m'en balance c'est pourquoi
parce que tu as des deux plus je lis pas
tout sera bien là mais on sait jamais vu
comme ça toi je n'ai jamais été comme ça
je m'en allais au cépage conquérir
quelques semaines tu veux qu'on aille à
miami tu que je te tiens tu commences à
travailler le chapeau toi peut-être
bombe à la forêt tels mère tu peux pas
d'argent je ne sais pas tout ce que je
sais c'est que j'aime pas cette villa
qui doit y avoir mieux j'en suis sûr on
tape et raison je souhaitais pas plus
maligne qu'avant mais c'est ce que je
savais pas c'est qu'il ya une autre
manière de dire que la mienne ou la
tienne
quelle manière de vivre tu avais avant
avec ton joueur de saxophone pouvoir il
était honnête un pouilleux oui il y fait
son travail lui depuis que j'ai tout
changé de mon travail je mets personne
n'a rien donné
il tentait de cambrioler une maison leur
lui aussi il travaille par exemple que
je tue
bonello mais ces chalets cambrioler une
maison qu'est ce que tu racontes
tu comprends rien à rien ça va aller
laisse tomber tes cancer un toit triple
cloche et toi espèce de danger public
ouais je t'ai pris dans la rue je peux
très bien tir m tu manges tu manges pas
tous les joueurs nocar est oui mais
quand je mangeais c'était sans toi tu
sais pas peut nuire à ta papa manière tu
passes ton temps avec tueur était
d'enlever ses chaussures tu veux je te
dis t'es un mec au groupe
tu dois je suis pas plus qu'une victoire
[Applaudissements]
à
chris patten 4 soup dutil ondes avec
gâteaux à rien de ce qui m'appartient me
coûte que 4 souhait que cette technique
ne t'appartient pas personne
n'appartient à personne c'est la loi ou
par le poids de la loi je pensais la loi
là où je serai maintenant equity bon
allez je me casse pas les oreilles si tu
ne fais pas ici mais là tu reviendras
nathan fait ça d'abord plus tard tout de
suite
non bien ici à partir d'aujourd'hui je
ne signerai plus rien tant que je ne
serai pas ce que je signe fais ce que je
te dis
ce
ouais nous arrive de fruits non arrive
je t'en prie avis
et bien c'est maintenant tout le corps
quoi y'a pas de quoi j'aime pas temps de
fouiner j'étais trop bon avec toi alors
quoi tu peux imaginer que j'étais arrivé
j'ai eu tort mais je peux personnes
autour de moi qui ne tient pas sa place
en 2000 pas très ragoûtant rien compris
et entendus ce que j'ai dit
par ici la sortie mais je peux pas
sortir comme ça aubin brouille toi je
t'ai s'est vu dans le coin salut
fasciste
ça s'est arrangé le succès est à ranger
et est ce que vous croyez est un droit à
la parole où étais tu viens faire
l'amour j'aime pas les plus riches
pourquoi pleurer tu es sûre chez moi
devient un peu bizarre non tous ces
histoires de bouquins qu'ils ont des
trains qui reviennent plus
un peu de science n'est pas sans danger
quand on vient
cette idée des ducs et billy c'était
peut-être une erreur on préférerait voir
en me fait penser à un vieux serpent à
lunettes verra là qu'est ce qu'il a fait
doit y en avoir trop dit vous savez
quand elle m'a appelé faciste
vraiment la saveur et à berlin
je suis à chicago alors ado sano
ds l'iac
il a jugé dans la poussette gars on
pourrait pas trouver quelqu'un qui la
rendra aussi peut-être qu'avant
je termine pas en retard je t'aime pas
les baffes
allez tu voudrais pas me rendre un grand
service
quoi
[Applaudissements]
kelly a déjà 35 quand elle rentre je la
somme quand aussi est lente
non ce n'est pas la première fois avec l
un est elle toujours à lui que j'ai
voulu l'espérons keller 1h35
vous venez de dire bon 1h36
à quelle heure elle sortait en jeu +5
6h08 quoi et ça fait 8 heures qu'elle
est partie des têtes de grands films au
programme
ouais ouais enfin bon mais ça c'est dur
quand on prend 8 heures il est peut-être
arrivé quelque chose vous le seriez déjà
et c'est peut-être fait attaquer encore
ça arrive tout le temps non pas le
contraire pas me lire
croyez qu'ils pensent de la téléphonie
cette patate encore des papiers à signer
mais ça peut pas attendre
[Musique]
les là que je lé là quelqu'un sur 20
heures n'est pas la tête de baldé qui
l'a vu sortir depuis qu'il l'a me rend
très brave étudiants de ma part que
c'est un miro allez retourne à chercher
tu es déjà fait toute la ville
maintenant on commence
tu as entendu ce que j'ai dit ouais
ouais ouais là où tu vas changer de
chaussettes
un sujet tu es sûr de pouvoir monter
l'escalier du ray me reposer ouf jamais
jamais jamais j'aurais couquet dans
arriverait réfléchi de ce que nous
allons discuter à son sujet à ce sujet
le mariage on mettait sa vraie cette
histoire un peu loin et continue à faire
un mauvais set moi je vais penser à
votre protection du point de vue légal 1
/ sur le papier le poster je cesserai
pas c'est une femme ne peut pas
témoigner contre son mari épousé là
on finit toujours par se faire harponner
avec les gonzesses
trois passes et d'un goût toute cette
pagaille deux ou trois bouquins le monde
change a ri la raison prend la place de
la force
le vrai pouvoir
c'est la connaissance kwh m l'habileté
suprême c'est l'honnêteté
ainsi va le monde bah oui mais moi je
n'aime pas beaucoup comment les choses
vont ici un avec vous qu'il est saoulé
pas puis la monde qui se fait en valent
rien
les sénateurs que vous m'avez amenée je
dois faire bouillir que ce n'est pas une
affaire
moi je ne trouve mignon café du coin on
est plein de sénateur comme ça ils sont
pas tous avant l'arrêt c'est ce qui fait
que tout va mal à washington trop donner
de gens
bon je venais jeter un coup d'oeil en
bas je verrais bien s'ils discutent ou
tu as déjà vu cette dernière arrive non
ouais bon ballon fou le camp ouais
[Musique]
ça va oui oui je crois c'est grave
je crois que je ne vous verrez sans
doute pas paul couach quoi alors je
voulais vous dire au revoir et merci
pour tout noah dit si c'est tout ce que
je sais et vous pouvez bien bleus virent
ne s'est pas d'abord j'irai peut-être
voir mon père pour avoir un repas chaud
mais oui alors j'ai une meilleure idée
laquelle bah oui on est où vous rigolez
je vous ai mobile et c'est pas moi que
vous aimez c'est mon cerveau pas
seulement
bon bah je vais réfléchir mais je peux
vous dire tout de suite que je
répondrais non mais qu'est ce que vous
faites
bah si vous ne le savez pas c'est que je
m'y prends mal
mais qu'est ce qui est plus important
tout de suite sa beauté projet d'art y
auront coulé lors les deux
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les cours du
soir
ou est ce que vous étiez je vous ai
cherché partout j'ai fait l'aller-retour
jusqu'à la maison blanche avant tout le
monde va bien la barre n'y a pas de
malade alors vous mon pote shaibu speed
rail un oui pourquoi
pourquoi pas ce que je vais lui dire que
je vais retrouver et je pense pas qu'il
aimerait vous voir tourner autour de sa
bonne femme au milieu de la nuit
il est un peu chatouilleux de ce côté là
je prends le risque vous feriez mieux de
partir
écoutez la elle a raison et qu'est ce
que ça peut vous faire avoue n'avoir
rien la grèce a fait rien mais la vue du
sang ça rend nerveux
tu vous en prie tout ira bien de vie
mais green guerilla au revoir vous dis à
bientôt
alors passez moi le portier halo portier
ici 67 d envoyer moi quelqu'un pour mes
bagages non non tout de suite c'est fini
qu'est ce qui t'arrive om monaco qui est
en plein dans le buffet
et pourquoi tu lui a pas rendu quoi
pourquoi tu y as par an dit il disait
bout devenir folle je commence à croire
qu'il a raison tu veux faire quelque
chose pour moi voyez quoi emballer
d'affaires là haut pour filer encore et
pour de bon vous voyez ça fait quelque
chose
vient alors pour lui dit on s'arrête
avant le coup dur les petits princes où
est ce que vous allez pathé à nyon vous
m'en voulait à moi aussi
dans un sens oui ok ce que je vous ai
fait moi ah qu'est ce que je vous ai
fait j'en veux à tous ceux qui accepte
tout voilà comment je suis à présent on
va essayer pas me faire travailler le
cerveau
hélas et d'enduits comme sarah vit août
afin de promener comme tu m'avais dit je
suis forcée qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je t'ai manqué j'aurais tendance une
nouvelle une bonne nouvelle mais quand
j'ai une idée je n'aime pas attendre
oui je sais maintenant je me demande ce
que tu mérites que sur la liste tient
dis toujours c'est sûr que tu aimerais
tu sais j'ai même dit à tête
il était inquiet lui mais pas moi pas
pour les mains
qu'est ce que tu as fait pendant tout ce
temps j'ai beaucoup réfléchi
ah oui à quoi un à situation non non
c'est juste le monde sait que je veux te
parler
oui y'a quoi de ta situation pris mon
père allait liquider ben j'aime pas en
avant mais pas et tout ce qui t'a france
avec temps brouillé puis 2e on va se
marier
non à condition que tu te surveille donc
et ça veut dire non non ça veut dire que
je veux pas tu jamais tu blagues ou quoi
dans pourquoi mais pour qui tu te prends
pour oser me dire non et si tu pas jeu
d'autres surprises en réserve
non mais répond d'abord quoi comment tu
peux refuser qu'on se marrer parce que
t'es trop bouché ça c'est une raison
et puis parce que j'ai envie de vivre
d'une autre façon
tu correspond plus à mon idéal mais kobe
mais je te comprends plus moi je le
comprends mais qu'est ce que cet effet
bon j'ai faite par l'effort de temps en
temps quoi tu as passé une ou deux fois
et alors là non c'est pas une raison
pour me traiter comme ça
guerre du café les jolis cadeaux aux 6,1
alors on pourrait pas s'arranger
non pourquoi non c'est vrai tout ce que
paul n'a dit tout ce que j'ai vu ça m'a
tout embrouiller
mais quand tu m'a tapé dessus là ça m'a
fait comprendre une chose c'est qu'ils
allaient gens qui donnent des coups et
d'autres qui les recevoir
alors j'ai plus envie de me laisser
faire ni par thouars ni par n'importe
qui j'ai une idée qu'on va monter europe
et je vais te calmer un peu
1 ça nous rappellera de bons temps tu te
souviens tu veux quand même mes amis
[Musique]
oui moi je te dis que tu devrais me
posais tu crois pas papillon mais
maintenant tu vas me pousse et puis
c'est tout j'ai laissé par leur
maintenant ça suffit
alors fais ce que je te dis où son
synthé graf j'ai plus peur des thoiry et
ça aussi c'est nouveau
t'as plus peur de moi
qu'est-ce que je n'allais pas dit je
m'en vais du tabac et pour déboucher
leur a pas mal à l'aise dans votre barre
est beau et plus vite que ça a donné
quelques détails arriver tu peux pas
tant d'années comme ça ma belle tu es
trop dans le coup avec moi et c'est ma
plus grosse combine alors j'ai peut-être
eu tort de tit m me tombent pas tort tu
y es tu passeras deux mois montre à
peine tu peux tout liquider ouais bon
d'accord le meilleur atout liquide alors
je n'ai pas de temps à perdre pour
pouvoir te tirer en vitesse
si j'ai été trop bon avec toi c'est pas
faute mais pour moi je veux dire tu es
plus bonne à rien oui tu sois une
associée une vraie associés toi tu veux
pas entendu ll ya qu à voir est ce que
l'avenir nous réserve sans moi puis je
préfère te dire tu as peu changé depuis
six ans à part les fonds en même temps
plutôt tarte
alors je suis sûr je suis content de
passer la main si comme la réponse vice
et versa
tanger à la ferme à voix qu'est ce qui
se passe en cause l'intérêt qui est
complètement dingue
alors on va tout régler entre nous
d'après le débarrasse le plancher vous
rendez compte de ce que vous faites
oui et pour la première fois de ma vie
bon tu dis non mais où est-ce que vous
avez four et toute cette paperasse
qu'elle doit signer québécois oussalah
c'était des couvertures bleues oui trois
copies oui je les ai donné à paul
quand maintenant quoi faire cette
question pour qui les publie dans son
journal
[Musique]
il en toile pour ce genre de blagues tu
repasseras oui je ne lâche pas post 10
et la plus salée stroke lis qu'on n'ait
jamais vu depuis 20 ans et vous êtes
tous pas là
pourtant vous avez dit vous que tout
était parfaitement régulier
seule petite moucharde pas mon avis si
un incendie que j'appelle les pompiers
qu'est-ce que je vous charge la serbie
j'appelle charme
non moi je sais qu'il faut appeler et d
y avoir 80 24 va dire à paul gayral
devenir tout de suite dit lui que ces
vides et qu'il demande mais je suis chez
harry vous pouvez pas c'est important
non pas possible eh bien elle n'a rien à
voir là dedans c'était une idée à moi
mais mes joueurs je vais te montrer
décider si tu crois que tu publies terre
par titre il a bavardé lunettes et une
vraie lui aussi sait pas comment ces
achats sont arrivés de vous tirer on est
mal parti mais je vais m'occuper de ce
gala a fait pas confiance à la botte au
premier départ on oublie qu'on fait je
vous dirais de mon tout à l'heure entre
cadieux toute façon si le projet
publiées + personnes marchent avec nous
ah oui vous avez une solution
vu les circonstances écouter aurait
peut-être mieux tout laisser tomber
ouais laisser le dénoncer un scandale si
rien ne se passe il serait ridicule je
sais rien il se passe
vous figurez j'ai caché ici de moi de ma
vie et tout ce fric pour tout laisser
tomber sa voix pourquoi parce qu'à pied
miro veut ouvrir sa grande gueule jeu
arrachant la langue c'est ce que vous
êtes un trouillard
vous le pensez tarek par erreur vous
avez pris quelque chose qui m'appartient
pas possible j'attends au bon soir
quelle bonne surprise
comment allez-vous très bien ted aller
chercher les papiers dans sa chambre ils
n'y sont pas ouais wissant alors bon ben
on voulait jouer au dur parfait ça me
connaît aussi
racontez-moi brevets finie la rigolade
parce que l'enjeu est trop gros alors
vous m'avez piqué quelque chose qui
m'appartient et si vous voulez sortir
d'ici avec tous vos membres
vous allez me le rendre mais je me suis
jamais dit qu'on ferait un tu peux lui
dire
il sait jamais dégonfler il a déjà
supprimé des genres comme celui qui a
été tué il ya six ans quand il y avait
une grève dans une cité par goal.com
bientôt tu pourras plus ne rien dire à
personne a pu ne rien dire à personne
double négation c'est une faute
c'est une foule
eh bien là j'ai l'impression que vous
vous rendez pas bien compte
alors si vous tenez un repos arrêt
attendu et à d'autres moyens
vous faites fausse route paul il est
tombé sur un os je vous conseille de
laisser tomber
moi je vous conseille t pas fort et
votre nez dans mes affaires c'est ça qui
font entendre et vous devrez parfois
maintenant mais ça faire moi je voulais
déjà les yaris est différent c'est mon
métier
quoi ma fiche de bâtons dans les roues
devant pas forcément bon alors qu'est ce
que c'est qu'est ce que c'est votre
métier si elle était loin je m'intéresse
à découvrir ce qui se passe et le faire
connaître au public
si je me dis que l'opération est
conforme à la loi annoncée la loi qu'il
faut changer
qu'est-ce que vous êtes vous le
gouvernement bien sûr depuis corps je
vais vous le dire depuis nice et 179
c'est ce à quoi mais bien sûr je suis le
gouvernement a ri qu'est ce que vous
pensez que c'est le gouvernement
un monstre une machine un homme et non
par ici vous c - des milliers de gens
nous avons des intérêts communs des
fonds à la mersey je trouve quand même
défendre tout seul vous fatiguez pas il
comprendra j'arrête
merci a dit alors n'a pas l'air de
s'ennuyer ici dagen
et il perd en valais votre sourire parce
que c'est pas le moment 1 mais quoi qu
est ce qui m'ennuie notre ami monsieur
véral ici présent est tombé sur un
paquet de documents je sais pas ce qu'il
en pense je vais vous le dire je pense
que le rapport qui existe entre
l'amendement déposé par le sénateur et
la sphère que veut monter harry est un
peu plus qu'une coïncidence minutes mon
petit ami voulez vous je ne suis pas
contre les idées avancées j'en ai vu
moi-même autrefois mais je ne vois pas
pourquoi vous vous en prenez
particulièrement tanoh et oui pourquoi
oh bien sûr vous n'êtes pas les seuls sa
pression pots-de-vin corruption la
république des petits camarades se
rencontrent souvent et si difficile à
combattre mais par hasard quand on a la
chance d'avoir en main du fait des
chiffres et surtout les nous et les ah
je vous prierais de faire attention
jeune homme quand vous parlez de
pontpoint en ma présence et les 40
millions vous avez touché comment vous
appelez ça un pourboire
paris oui je pense en attendant mieux
foutu repensé et attirer ou garder on a
c'est raconter des histoires maintenant
elles ont buté sur vos projets rien
votre avocat dit que tout est régulier
bien sûr alors pourquoi vous inquiéter
j'aime pas le bruit c'est oh non je
parle doucement oui qu'est ce que vous
voulez paul whisky soda c'est possible
mais en fait pas le ballet avec moi j'ai
jamais rencontré personne qui n'est pas
son prix moi si ah oui mais attention je
parle gros chiffres au toit était gros
chiffres si tu continues tu vas finir
par emporter un en prison
ouais j'suis à quoi tout à l'heure c'est
pas compliqué c'est pas compliqué vous
acceptez on n'en parle plus ou bien
c'est moi qui vous le dit où que vous
alliez vous vivrez pas vu et compris il
faudra qu'ils pensent vous avez deux
minutes
/
[Musique]
vous venez de nous mettre dans vos bras
il ya des trucs que je peux pas
supporter qu'est-ce que vous ne pouvez
pas supporter nous ne supportons miel
depuis des années que vous soyez encore
en liberté
vous devriez dire merci espèce de gros
bagouet bas vous ne me connaissez pas
aussi je vous connais vous et vos
pareils j'en ai vu déjà des blancs
départ l'un des chefs des grands des
petits
vous êtes toujours les mêmes vous
occupez partout le meilleur appartement
de poissy les tout le charbon le bois
l'acier l'aluminium le pétrole mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez encore les
hommes les loin
50 millions qu'est-ce que vous l'ayez de
50 millions 50 millions
c'est une somme
non je peux pas accepter pourquoi ma
femme n'aimeraient pas ça
certainement pas
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez rien
seulement vous empêcher d'acheter de
vendre notre législation comme de la
ferraille puisque voix comptées mais
comme je peux rien de mal bah ouais
cette fameuse liberté d'entreprise on
nous rabat les oreilles la barre
qu'aurait fait après d'entreprise mois
on voulait parce que moi je réussis vous
pas voilà tout est là tout le monde a
les mêmes choses ce n'est pas moi j'ai
commencé comme les autres gosses à
wissant maintenant les eaux nulle part'
elisa tous virés accueillis dans le tue
j'ai toujours faste où j'ai voulu s
continuerait et ben vas-y tu m'empêchera
nous deux ça ce serait un joli pays le
jour où un corniaud une poule pour
empêcher un type comme moi de travail
qu'est-ce que vous avez d'être sourd et
muet pourquoi je vous paye bon dieu et
quelque chose hein je vais dire quelque
chose alors ils ont raison quand assurés
quoi
une autre fois peut-être harry mais
parce qu'aussi et si vous voulez
continuer dépêchez vous car les gens
commencent à se rendre compte et ça va
devenir de plus en plus difficile pour
vous et vos pareils
la démocratie est une mécanique délicate
et nous ne laisserons pas démolir par
des gars comme vos seins démocratie
pourra connaître tout ce que vous voulez
mais empêche le parterre ce que je vois
je vais te dire ce que tu vas faire toi
et comment j'ai peur que tu m'aies
oublié
j'ai peur que tu oublié je suis associé
cette maladie souvent ses 126
entreprises que je possède contrôle
c'est pareil mais j'en veux pas je veux
rien avoir à faire avec toi avec tes
sales combines
alors je vais peut-être mais pas d'un
seul coup une à une puis par an
c'est dit on dit bien parce que si tu te
convient pas bien riec pour ce que tu as
fait depuis que je te connais ça doit
aller chercher dans les 900 ans de
prison et bien la sortie tu seras pas là
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est l'évolution
au sein va pas lé genre devraient
chercher mise à faire ça va chercher là
bas avec tu t'en rappellera cette
journée c'est moi qui te le dis avec tu
vas voir où ça va nous mener quant à
vous moi je vous dire vous travaillez
plus pour moi on sait thomas jarry ça me
plaisait bien ouvre toi
bonsoir tout le monde
qu'est ce que vous en dites
il pouvait avoir de 50 millions elle
trouve un bavoir pour marie puis
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont maintenant des
clous
ce corniaud oui c'est beau mais très
juste à tous les camions à toutes les
peaux mais passés présents et futurs qui
ont soif de savoir qui cherche la vérité
qui combattent pour la justice et qui
rendent la vie difficile aux salopards
comme vous vous êtes comme moi
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous dans l'adaptation française de
grognard et rené clair et de garson
kanin
le décor et de roger à
[Applaudissements]
les costumes de donald cardwell
la mise en scène de pierre mondy
avec jean hébert
christiane muller
andré valtier
les tarifs york
patrick brisson
michel beaumont
jacques balutin
bah caso
pierre mondy
ah bah non
et avec louis velle
[Musique]